all right
great crowd first i just want to ask if
everyone um if we can have a show of
hands
who who's familiar with tilt formerly
known as crowd tilt
okay right a good number but james if
you could just
give us your elevator pitch anyone who
doesn't know what's what's tilt
and what are some of the latest numbers
you can give us tilt is the easiest way
man this is a sensitive mic
tilt is the easiest way to collect money
from a group for free
so it is a lot of ways to a startup
crowd
one of the ways to describe it is is
really goes back to our why commoner
application which is
what will crowdfunding look like in a
mobile world and what type of
crowdfunding
will translate into a mobile context
i can go into more detail but to
consumers and to college kids
uh it's really just the easiest way to
collect money from a group
yeah for like a party yep instead of
like a 50 000
uh documentary a hardware project on
something like kickstarter it's a 1 500
late night party on a college campus 2
000 bucks for a friend's 30th birthday
um your fantasy football league or it is
uh 900 bucks for a party bus up to napa
all of those kinds of friends friendly
group objectives we've just borrowed our
favorite elements from crowdfunding
platforms and provided for groups of
friends instead
great and uh you guys have gotten really
large obviously but i want to kind of go
back to the early days
and talk about where this all began
because it wasn't just crowd tilt in the
earlier days you even had
an earlier iteration of that what sort
of inspired you to say i'm gonna
you know graduate from college and just
start my own thing and become an
entrepreneur how did how did that happen
well i've been starting things for the
last 10 years or so
in college started a fly fishing company
for any fly fishing fans out there i
started a non-profit a fellowship grant
program for
for research in in the field of study
that i
that i focus on development economics
and my senior year i started to come up
with this concept
for grouping loans to
micro insurance organizations so if
you're familiar with kiva.org it was
essentially
kiva for micro insurance organizations
total mouthful won't get into it
that was actually one of the biggest
lessons i learned was just
a niche niche application of the
software was really hard to educate
people on
but um but yeah i think i was always had
this energy beneath my feet to start
things
and really saw really a big opportunity
to apply this technology and
and the power of the connected web to
the developing world
started building that out and actually
what i realized was
this was 2009 2010 before crowdfunding
really had a
name or was codified and realized wow
this little feature of
of this application groups pulling their
money towards an
objective i was basically like holy
that's going to this is going to be so
much bigger than just an application of
micro you know towards micro insurance
organizations and felt like crowdfunding
itself
um was going to be the next layer of the
web
how did you decide that that one part of
your first company was the most
important
part of it because i'd imagine that
there were other parts of the company
that you were
passionate about how did you focus and
say okay i'm gonna
focus on this one and let these other
parts go
i think it was it was um it was the only
part we got right
uh we i made so many mistakes i still
make so many mistakes
every single day i tell but um that kind
of we
you know did so much we did so much
wrong of
you know we built this thing for 19
months didn't tell anyone about it
because we thought it was
this secret we needed to just keep close
to the vest and
and did all these things wrong i was at
that point in time
with um you know people getting people
on board i was
so young 22 23 years old that i really
wanted anyone that was that was willing
to listen to me
i would make them a co-founder bring
them on board and it was
and it was kind of um you know when
you're when you're that young you
really look for validation at every at
every turn with tilt it was very
different it was
all right i need to make sure that we're
doing this with with the right people so
i did all these things wrong
the thing that stuck with me in the back
of my head that kind of
just i couldn't shake was man this
identity driven web
um this connected web if you add
finances to it if you add money to it
it can have such a massive impact on an
offline world
that online communities and and
communication um
you know forums or facebook or uh
twitter just
it's amazing for communication but
impacting the offline world requires
a lot of resources oftentimes finances
so it's kind of that was the
little key insight that we got right um
and started it
and i started to think about man how
could this be applied in a more
horizontal or much more broad sense than
just micro insurance or development
okay and when you decided to focus on
crowd tilt at that time it was called
crowdtilt
um how did you find your co-founder your
cto
yeah the the best advice i ever got as
and i i still think about this pretty
often the best advice i ever got
um as an entrepreneur was and and
i still i contend it's the best advice i
might ever get
um everyone write this down i guess yeah
i was in a coffee shop
in south africa in cape town south
africa where i was building the first
crowdfunding application
um called develop if you want to look it
up it's uh
i was in a coffee shop with an
entrepreneur down there in south africa
and the entrepreneur told me the two
most
important things to build anything of
significance
is trust in a network and it's those two
things
um trust in a network and i've look i've
googled this i've looked it up i
i don't see anyone that really talks
about it in simplifying
terms like this but he said you know the
idea isn't the most important thing
you'll refine the idea you'll be wrong
and so many points
as many points as you're right the
capital isn't the most important thing
that can come with
with a network the the people recruiting
is going to be so much
harder than you you really think when
you're just getting going and it's just
you and your dorm room or something
and um and so all of those things that
you're going to need to build something
of of massive significance
um it's going to depend on these two
elements trust in a network
and the key to it that he said was uh
one is worthless without the other
if you have a big network but uh you
know you went to hbs but no one trusts
you
and it's more or less pointless um if
you have a lot of trust but it's only
your mom
then it also isn't isn't kind it isn't
uh
as valuable so as both of those things
and
both of those things have resulted in so
many um so much good fortune for for us
as a company
um specifically my co-founder was just
through
a network of investors down in austin a
couple ctos down in austin there's one
specific cto
that really loved what i was building
with tilt and called crowlthen
really loved kind of this crowdfunding
for the everyman type of
approach to this space wanted to invest
and wanted it to be successful enough to
where he said
hey there's a guy that one you should
have a co-founder and two
there's a guy down here at rackspace he
runs strategies
26 very young but really really rare
combination of technical and strategic
thinking
if i was going to start my next company
he's who i would start it with so see if
you can if you can rope him into what
you're building his name's caleb
uh come down and grab a coffee with him
and i was like i heard that i was like
good god i've got to get this guy on
board and it was really through that
introduction
and and typically doesn't happen that
way with co-founders but that's how it
happened with us
how do you think about your network when
you say you've got to have a network
you know that can't just be everyone
that you've ever met and especially
everyone here is busy
you know you're a very busy person how
do you maintain a network while you're
also building a company
i think it's hard to
it's really hard to articulate it or
verbalize
kind of a process around it because it
oftentimes if you apply a process to it
you'll actually shoot yourself on the
foot it actually should be much more
organic
mutually beneficial but i think one of
the things that
that i'd highlight is you build this
network and everyone if you're
if you're here then you're good at
building networks uh most likely
and that's one of the things you have to
hustle at most um
but you i would i would phrase it as you
go into it knowing you
will only need to actually call upon two
to three percent of your network
um in some utility fashion it really you
build this massive network and
most of the time you actually won't need
anything from them um
and it's always a surprise where you do
need something and who you end up
needing it from so you really can't go
into it thinking a quid pro quo
um taking that type of mentality you
actually
much like a startup much like a
technology start
you have to go into it thinking i'm
going to provide as much value as
as i can i'm going to create as much
value as i possibly can
i'm going to help this person that
person this person that person with
whatever i can and create as much value
as possible and not
think about how can i capture value um
how is this person valuable to me
it has just happened so many times um
and granted a young founder with with uh
limited exposure but it still has
happened so many times in our career
and in my career that had i gone into it
thinking
you know a premeditated approach of how
can this person help me
i would have missed out on the
introduction to my my co-founder for
example that was
happenstance coffee with i was at a a a
conference much
like this actually and gary vee was
speaking and i was trying to get
uh in front of gary vee as you know 24
or something thinking
i've got to get this this guy i was in
dallas building uh tilt out of my
bedroom and essentially i felt like man
no investors come through dallas i've
got to get in front of this guy
i thought garyvee was like the most
important person to get in front of in
an
auditorium very much like this right
after the conference ended and
one of the other speakers a guy named
bill babel was kind of just off by
himself and there was a line of 50
people trying to get in touch with gary
and get in front of garyvee and and no
one was talking to this guy bill babel
arguably that was the most important
contact i ever made um and it was
kind of not trying to quid pro optimize
for
gaining something it was like hey this
guy might have something really
interesting
to say he had a good good speech chatted
with him and now he's
he's probably our most uh impactful
angel that we have
that's great um and tilt went through y
combinator
right how was that experience what kind
of takeaways do you have from the
incubator experience is that something
you'd recommend to
to other founders yes i would um
there's there's some irony in it in that
going into it
we didn't know what the value would be
so we were you know out in texas and
didn't
um and really had so much confidence and
overconfident that we were like no we
don't need
any incubator program and thought uh
larry and sergey didn't need an
incubator program so
neither do we um but one of the things
that i think it's
it is so so valuable to tie it into a
thread from a previous question
is that network that you can build
through an incubator program
is just so quick it's um you can fast
forward
you know y combinated for us that was
probably uh
that accelerated 10 years of being out
in the valley of
a network that we would have had to
build much more organically
you know i think it's it is i think it's
stated enough so it's
it's not that it it's understated the
power of that network
um that you get from an incubator
program but i know we still had doubts
about it
and really felt like you know what we're
going to build was going to be on our
shoulders and we're going to have to be
the ones to do it and
the truth is every single day it's you
know i'm
i i probably lean on that network uh in
some form or fashion
so um that's part of i i'd say part of
the biggest reason that people
young founders should think about it
founders in general should think about
it
and tilt has been in this category in
the crowdfunding category which
has been really buzzed about in recent
years so you guys were sort of fortunate
to ride that wave in certain ways but i
wonder if that's a double-edged sword
in any way when you're building a
company that's part of
almost a fad or something that's like a
buzz term whoa whoa whoa
colleen don't call it a fad not a fad
i'm gonna quote you on that in five
years
colleen taylor said crowdfunding was a
fad no but anyone could be
right anyone could be building something
now with the
sort of technology of the month you know
um
and no it's it's it's a very valid valid
question i think it it is a double-edged
sword
at times i think for the most part um
you know we we kind of we look at our
approach to it
and and if you you know you download the
app we just launched on android
uh last week and if you if you download
the app it doesn't feel like
crowdfunding i think it is
um kind of along those lines of
borrowing our favorite elements from
crowdfunding
and applying it kind of in our own way
to smaller groups and and
kind of a more everyday type of
objective the um
the the press does kind of toss it into
crowdfunding
but for the most part you know silicon
valley isn't really our user base it's
not really
the the early adopter set isn't really
our user base so i don't think it really
affects us too much
mainly because if you are a fraternity
social chair and you use tilt and it
works really really well then you don't
really care what
segment it's in or it's kind of like you
know i didn't
come across or find value in facebook
because it was a social network i just
used it within a few weeks i thought you
know i'm finding value in this product
so it's um for our users i don't think
it really comes into
into play the um but i think with
recruits and things like that it's
something that it does you know you've
got to meet us to
to hear our different take on it or
investors you've got to
meet us to hear our different take on it
i mean but
uh it is i think
it's one of these spaces where it's it's
like blogging was 10 15 years ago where
there's so much hand waving about it um
there's so much
attention given to it i remember you
know 10 15 years ago
everyone was saying what's going to
happen when everyone has ink by the
barrel and there's no journalistic
integrity anyone can just throw up an
article and people are taking it as fast
and to be honest um you know blogging
and online publishing has been one of
the most radically transformative things
that that
our world um is has been improved by
um but it actually took six seven years
for actually the second generation of
of these tools to come along and really
bring it to the to the mainstream
the crowdfunding today only has a couple
hundred thousand people across all the
major platforms
um us uh kickstarter indiegogo um
gofundme there's only a couple hundred
thousand people that have crowdfunded
before
if you actually add it up and you know
10 15 years ago there's one to two
million long-form bloggers in the world
um you fast forward now with something
like twitter there's 270 million long
online publishers and it almost looks
unrecognizable from the first generation
of publishing tools or
wordpress i think techcrunch is powered
by wordpress
perfect example the second generation
tools almost look unrecognizable from
livejournal or blogger
i think crowdfunding over the next five
years is going to
um it's going to show itself as as one
of the decade defining phenomenons
um but i don't think it's actually hit
the mainstream like uh
like we hope it will and when you think
about press
and messaging and these kinds of things
um do you have any lessons learned on
that front
since most of your users aren't
necessarily
in silicon valley what have been some of
the most valuable ways for you to get
the word out
about tilt yeah you just
you keep it really simple um that's the
the best the
best advice i can give and we kind of
learned this we learned this
just by touching the hot stove and
getting burned burned excuse me
i think it's keep it simple um for you
know
consumers and the messaging to consumers
all we stick to is
is the easiest way to collect money from
a group we don't get into
the philosophy behind what we're
building while we're building it and
it's so
easy to feel like you should um you know
it's
it is um around here people say is it
it's kind of like venmo for groups be
like sure that's a very good way of
describing it and you have to be
comfortable with that super super simple
straightforward application or
description
for press for consumers
and not get caught up in kind of this
really grandiose thinking of why you're
building what you're building
we would see that especially going
through y combinator you see that with a
lot of yc founders
they really want to jump into why this
is going to be
the biggest thing ever and sometimes you
actually you should be okay with hey
this is just some simple little thing to
make a tiny part of your life a little
bit easier
so i think that's helped us with with
press so you just kind of have to
trust that the people will know what to
do with it and you don't have to preach
to them
right you just you trust that the most
important thing is
get their kind of foot get the foot in
the door get them to download it or
understand how they can use it today
and as a company you can actually
harness it
and feel very you know empowered by how
big something can become
but you know one of the things that that
i would say in a group like this is i i
think
crowdfunding will go from a couple
hundred thousand people to a couple
hundred million
um using and making use of crowdfunding
in the next five ten years but
to the kid on to the sigma chi
at ucla's campus he doesn't really care
he just wants to get people to pitch in
for the keg or something exactly right
um and is there one or a couple of
different
press mentions that you guys have had
that you've really seen an uptick from
that you would recommend and say hey if
you can get on the today show get on the
today show
or something that you thought would be a
bigger boost but actually
wasn't yeah i'd say the in today's world
it is um and and you know this as well
it's just
there are there's more publishing
happening every single day than
um than i think the previous 2000 years
of human history
as a 10 years ago um so it's just so
much
is online i think the biggest thing you
should do
as a founder as as early stage employee
is just focus on your product and your
customers not worry about press
at all actually the best companies are
often
so misunderstood in their first few
years and and even just
trying to articulate in a few words what
an app does
what an app a really powerful app does
it is
it really kind of it misses the point um
because if i mean just look at your home
screen and try to describe to someone
why an app is so cool um you know it is
really really hard
and now you know with the with
the apps becoming mainstream something
like facebook you don't have to describe
it but
rewind 10 years and try to describe
facebook to to someone or
or just imagine you describing it to
your mom it is really really difficult
um to describe it and press often
misunderstand it
so i think those products and those
companies did a really good job of just
focus
focusing on their customers and not
worrying about press too much at all
right and we have a few minutes left and
so if anyone has questions definitely
start
okay i have i think there are
microphones great and so while we're
getting the microphone
um my last question is you now have
70 some people and you've started with
building these ideas
by yourself in a basement for 19 months
so what's the biggest shift
that you've had to make as a person when
you go from being the ceo
or co-founder of a couple people to to
70 plus
i think the um one of the things i've
learned
is it is all about endurance and
persistence this is a game of endurance
um there's a great book called born to
run if if
you guys are familiar with it about a
tribe in um
in mexico that would run hundreds of
miles
um and the author notes just how like
the
the modern world views running as it's
like childbirth
it's this uh this very very painful
thing that once it's all done
and over with the sacrifice and the pain
is worth it the truth is
you know one of the things that the
author cites is
is just how wrong
we view running and you know
historically
and that this tribe in mexico run
hundreds of miles and enjoy every single
step have fun
25 miles into a run and
it is kind of that was i think one of
the things that i have gotten so wrong
and thought so wrong about startups
you think about the idea or writing an
equation on class and
on a window and it's like that's what
it's about and it is so much about
endurance and loving every single step
of the journey
and i think that is the biggest surprise
the cliche the journey is the
destination is so
friggin true it is so true so you gotta
love every step
that's great okay okay i guess uh first
question
what issues have you had with regulatory
compliance and navigating all that with
crowdfunding and especially with
cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency like bitcoin yes so we do
have an open source tool it's the most
popular
open source crowdfunding tool uh in the
world that we kind of just released
last year and that has bitcoin you can
actually plug in bitcoin to it
but for the most part we haven't
implemented bitcoin into our core app
because it just hasn't been a huge uh
request from
from our users internally we are
extremely excited about it so it's a
customer base issue basically for
getting that rolled out
right it is like it we will get tweets
pretty often of uh when you guys can
i'd say in terms of our company dna
we're pretty developer centric
engineering-centric uh crowdfunding
company maybe
maybe the most developer-centric
crowdfunding company out there
so we hear it we want it badly but
um just pragmatically it hasn't been
requested enough by our users
um on the regulatory side of things you
know we really make use and leverage
things like stripe um braintree
uh skrill adian international a payment
processor as we
as we go international and leveraging
them we don't have to deal with
nearly the compliance or or regulatory
issues that we would if
if we're doing it all in a house so for
to a large degree we just get to focus
on building
the social software on top of those
layers so outsource is the answer
sometimes
yes big time big tongue uh division of
labor and kind of uh separation of
of concern i'm a big big believer in
leaning on others
uh to solve those hard problems when you
can't yeah all right
so you said uh the most important things
are
trust and a network and you said that
incubator accelerates a network
so it got me thinking what if anything
could accelerate trust
because that's the other side of the
equation that is a damn good question
corey
accelerating trust i don't know if you
can accelerate
trust
i think one of the ways that you can
kind of get to that to the
that result um is in silicon valley one
of the things that you can just is a
pleasant byproduct of this part of the
world is the hyper connectivity of your
network
and so if a certain subset trusts you
that trust can scale really quickly
um a pretty unprecedented levels
actually
i know from a user-based perspective
from a fraud prevention
perspective we can know more about
someone in
just five minutes of cursor research
online on that person that's collecting
twenty thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars you know high dollar amounts
um we can know more about them today in
2015 than you could have known ten years
ago with
meeting them four times and getting
their um
their credit score i mean
you can know so much about people today
um that it probably
that probably spills into your personal
network if you have trust
amongst you know 16 close close friends
or 16
really close mentors in in the bay area
that can scale really quickly
and those intros and the connectivity
can scale but
in terms of accelerating that trust with
those 16 people
i think it's just one of those things
you've got to approach every single day
knowing that it's a constant investment
one of the biggest mistakes you can make
is thinking
that all right this startup didn't work
this idea didn't work
now i've i'm embarrassed that it didn't
work and now i've actually burned these
bridges
we had a nobel um a nobel laureate as an
advisor in my first
startup and i thought that i was like
this thing is i'm about to email
all of our users that were shutting this
down
and and all of my favorite professors
all my favorite mentors and
and this the founder of microfinance
this is kind of this is going to be a
huge bummer and probably kill this
relationship and it was
it was the furthest thing from what
actually happened
so that trust definitely definitely
traverses whatever you're working on
to whether it goes well or whether it
goes uh south
just know that it's a constant
investment yeah maybe we could say
it's not something you could celebrate
but if you protect an integris
reputation then
you're good a thousand percent and
protect it with your life because
as the warren buffett quote goes uh it
takes 20 years to build trust and five
seconds to lose it
there it is awesome thanks thank you
good question last question
hi thanks for doing a talk with us um
i was actually really interested in the
fact that you mentioned it sounds like
you have really good product market fit
on college campuses
if you talk about how you've iterated on
your process of
basically user acquisition strategy
maybe talk about some strategies that
you've tried and didn't work and maybe
you failed fast and what
has worked for you so paul graham has a
great
essay that um essentially comes down to
this thesis of c randomness
um sometimes the world is just random
and more often than not
the world is just random so the answer
i'm about to give you um
it i don't know if it's going to be as
satisfying as
fireside chat questions usually strive
to be but i honestly think it's the
truth
we felt ass backwards into virality i
knew nothing about virality i knew
nothing about
um you know product design around
virality
and 11 months in 12 months in sean
parker
um just comes busting through the door
and
he's our largest individual investor and
just talked
about how we nailed this this uh viral
coefficient
when you start a tilt you invite on
average
24 people 18 will join and from that a
subset will start their own tilts
so by definition you use the product you
start a campaign
and you have to invite others to use it
and because it's kind of this you know
it's not a 50 000
documentary it has this very everyday
type of
every man's type of use case that
chances are of those 18 people
a subset are going to split off and
start their own campaigns and then a
subset are going to split off
split off and split off so our user
acquisition was
and always has been um just that that
natural virality
when you use evernote you could really
love it but it takes you know a lunch
for you to tell a friend hey i love this
product
with tilt you start using it by
definition you have to invite others to
use it
with you that virality was always really
high but when we looked at where the
virality was highest it was college
campuses
and and so we went from a product that
just has
we've been fortunate enough to grow
since day one to uh focusing on the user
demographic where it grows
it was growing fastest the activation
energy was lowest
that is why we focused on on colleges
but it actually took us a long time to
to find that that was uh that was the
case but
uh sadly we always had this
uh i say sadly because it's really hard
to give this advice have virality in
your application
uh but that was just the the truth of
the matter uh we just had virality
and uh we kind of fell as backwards into
it and then just really try to work hard
to iterate on it
great thank you sure all right thank you
james that's you that's all the time we
have thank you
thank you guys thank you thank you
colleen